[Music]
Kitty hey hey Kitty
are you okay
I was doing that thing again wasn't I
yeah you were I remember having lunch
with Jim he started to talk about this
kind of forest girl who had a special
gift of connection with living things
and she's going to be about 14 and you
and I know how immature you are so I
think you can handle this I said Thank
you when you see Sigourney play a
character a quarter of her actual age
flawlessly she steeped herself in the
ways of teen girls hi Mom but
unconsciously she just became younger it
was crazy to observe why can't I just be
like everyone else
I don't think any of us are very far
away from our 14 year old cells it's
such a strong memory how great it was
and how awful it was and I just sort of
fell in love with the character Jim has
this amazing ability to write straight
into the heart of a character why am I
different performance capture gives
actors the opportunity to play
characters that they could not otherwise
play and Kyrie's character and
sigourney's performance are the perfect
example of that given by one of the
great actresses of our time
they took him I have had to work
completely differently than I ever have
before because you do have to strip away
all of that Sigourney Weaver whoever
that is and it's been an amazing
experience to go back in time and be
with that person every day she clicks
into the character that she is and it's
like talking to a 14 year old I find it
fascinating that she can Channel this
young girl whatever it is I'm enjoying
watching it that's what I say it was a
heartbeat sound like
Mighty
she's marvelous to watch her it's such a
work of art you're watching like a
flower unfold and all of a sudden you do
not recognize that you are talking to a
woman that is 5 10.
that has walked this Earth for decades
and has made her Mark there so clearly
is mischievous little girl in Sigourney
she can be as imperious as you want she
can also be a complete knucklehead
it's a big Journey for her and for the
audience with her because it's okay
because she care about her she has a
luminous quality to see her playing a 14
year old kid it was magic it's what
acting is all about avatars only go
around
thank you
[Music]
[Music]